the next store we have is is coming off
of the impeachment from this weekend
the democrats definitely benefited from
fake news
but they also benefited from the fake
news they created with the evidence that
they doctored
so i don't know if you guys saw this
will jordan the uh
the tweets and the selective video so i
think everybody noticed the videos were
off
they cut what trump said they added
audio like after or in between
but more importantly they actually
showed a tweet that they totally just
made
my favorite my favorite i don't know if
it was a screw-up or not
was when a woman tweeted we're bringing
the calvary
and then was it eric swalwell said she
said she's bringing the cavalry
you guys know what the calvary is it's
like it's like a religious thing i don't
know exactly it's a representative
it's i could be wrong that is a
reference to the hill that jesus died on
it's a very strong religious reference
and i completely understand what she's
saying there she's like trying to bring
religion into it and make it be like a
almost like a crusade which also i don't
really like but i kind of
understand that better it is an open-air
representation of the crucifixion of
jesus
and they did bring the cross and raised
it on the capitol there you go they were
bringing the calvary
and he said cavalry as if to imply they
were going to be storming the gates on
horseback they clearly didn't know what
they were talking about well there's
more there's more than that there was a
i mean they changed the date
on a tweet right that might seem small
but that's the year
well so but that wasn't in the actual
trial that was in the new york times
but this is where the media comes in to
lie to everyone once again
check the story out from business
insider they say trump lawyer accuses
house managers of manipulating evidence
by pointing to doctored tweets that
weren't
used in the impeachment trial do you
hear that weren't
used in the impeachment trial was it in
the briefing it was used in the
impeachment trial
what happened was swalwell created he
recreated tweets why well donald trump's
account has been banned
in his recreation an image that was
shown in the new york times had the
wrong date january 3rd 2020
when they presented that same doctored
tweet it was actually two tweets
in one graphic image they corrected it
to 2021.
to say that they didn't use that simply
because they altered it slightly
to a certain degree is absolutely insane
because what
what trump's lawyers were saying was
they added the verification badge
to make it seem like trump was quoting a
public figure
probably of some prominence telling
people to
show up in dc and to bring the cavalry
which like the funny thing was when he
was saying that
the actual image said calvary like they
didn't know what it was
and i remember when this happened in the
trial i saw an actual lefty journalist
say cavalry or calvary does this guy not
know the difference
and this is like a lefty journalist he
didn't that's that you know what man
maybe the only reason this guy got in is
because phangfong was propping him up
he's still on the house intelligence
committee yes
i mean go back 30 years major any
politician during the cold war
gets caught like oh you slept with a
russian spell right
that's it like that's the end of your
career you are asked to resign by that
your
your party your own party how can we how
can we not be demoralized
when you have a guy who
was aided in his in his campaign for
office by a chinese spy he was
he was sleeping with her right literally
yeah he was sleeping with her those are
the allegations he was all out
but he won't answer specifically if he
did or didn't so some people are saying
guilt by association by by not even
responding
well i don't agree with that some people
are saying that but i'd like proof but
let's just
we know he he was associated and working
with and she was helping his campaign
that's a fact i wouldn't want to see the
proof i mean oh my gosh
she had to she had to you know be with
mr swalwell
there was a there was a babylon bee
article he's the guy who farted on tv
remember
yes yeah i mean i mean the man
also parroted a lot of the communist
chinese government
talking points throughout his uh career
fang fang was very instrumental in
raising a lot of funds for his election
and uh the babylon b article said
something like
uh chinese spy sent to internment camp
because she was forced to sleep with uh
eric swalwell
chosen tournament camp specifically to
avoid
sleeping with follow-up you know again
satirical article
uh but but again should should have been
covered more
there should be more attention to this
there should have been at least more
hearings about what actually was
released especially with him being on
the
on the intelligence committee hearings
like what information does china have
from eric here's the point i wanted to
make here's a guy
who definitely needs to be investigated
because of his association with a
chinese spy
and he's leading impeachment presenting
doctored evidence yeah and look i i
there's almost no point in having the
argument over the veracity or the
severity of the doctrine evidence
you know that the left goes oh it was
just a verification badge it's
meaningless and i'm like i
literally don't care they they created
that
try that in a federal court yeah you'll
get right they'll throw you out they'll
be like what do you how dare you
sanction you and you will face
discipline at the bar
right if you doctor any sort of evidence
in any way yeah
it's not just doctored he manufactured
the image
it was edited together and they and and
the argument is but it's because trump's
account was deleted
it doesn't matter you can go into the
archives and the woman's tweets still
exist
instead he just manipulated an image
that to me is mind-blowing it shows you
that this was a completely unserious
trial
and then they he just we all knew it was
going to happen
trump is acquitted so i'm sorry man it
is entirely demoralizing
what do we do you know we i've talked
about culture winning the culture where
i understand
making movies you know ben shapiro is
doing movies we have uh now gina corona
i was gonna be doing some with with the
daily wire
how do we deal with this i mean you know
i've been thinking about this myself
because you know i've been mostly over
the last couple years i've been doing
like opinion and commentary
and it's been you know it was aimed kind
of towards influencing republicans
right like not only i mean you know
defending trump from various things that
i think he was unfairly attacked but
also trying to change the republican
perspective
on things like social media big tech
free markets et cetera
now it's like we again we're confronted
with this bainly awful
administration combined with it's you
know conjoined bainly awful institutions
like the new york times
like we need to you need to report on
them they need you know there needs to
be like really good
i mean i think you start with media
because cultures you know politics is
downstream of culture
but we also just need really good
reporting on them um
we need real journalism and uh real
fearless journalism that's willing to
challenge these major institutions and
it seems like
off the top of my head there's only one
name i can think of and it's veritas
they just got banned from twitter i know
right so
they they give they throw every smear in
the book at james o'keefe
and to me it's crazy i certainly think
james is a point of view
i certainly think he's you know right
leaning or conservative i mean he speaks
it like cpac
and stuff like that right but it doesn't
matter to me i don't i don't care what
your politics are is what you're telling
me true
and important and whenever i look at say
you know veritas is reporting i take
into consideration
all framing and the issue is james
doesn't make
opinion commentary like the new york
times does he just publishes a video and
says here's what they said
now maybe you can accuse them taking
these out of context but
why should that phase me when they do it
all day every day
at the very least their argument is
james as bad as they are
or the same as they are there's good
reporting from the times and i try
i try my best to find it and sometimes
they do things like this they do it all
too often
so what well you can't trust a news
outlet that's that afraid of their
readers
i mean the new york times is terrified
of their subscribers
so like why are we trusting anything
that they're saying you know like you're
just
telling these people what they want to
hear because you're so afraid and then
this goes back to the culture war too
like why are we losing the culture war
we're terrified of pissing people off
like we just need to stop being afraid
of pissing everybody off
that's it's the craziest thing to me
like since when are conservatives
worried about offending hollywood
like you're never going to be in those
movies dude they hate your guts i hate
you
they're going to hate you no matter what
you say yeah it's just ridiculous
that's a really good point there was
something i saw for uh about fox news
where i think it was
was it lachlan murdoch is that his name
yeah he said something like we're gonna
be a center right
organization because the right way a
news organization serves its audience is
to like present them information
that they they want to hear whatever or
they agree with something like that
i don't know exactly what he said but
that's exactly it
we've gone from news organizations say
things i don't like but
you know that's the news it used to be
that people trusted the news outlet
and if they heard they didn't like they
didn't blame the news outlet for saying
it
now they do yeah i don't i don't think
all hope is lost i think there's a
reason a lot of these media companies
had to turn off their comments
i think there's a reason why you know
ins uh
apps like telegram and signal are doing
as well as they are
and uh just even just looking at the
latest comments from the 60 minutes bill
gates interview
there's a lot of interesting comments to
say the least and
i just looked up eric swalwell on
twitter and one of the first thing that
comes up
is a happy valentine's day card with him
and fang fang on it
so the the culture there the the the
resistance the
people informing themselves and
understanding what's going on i i i
think
that there's more of that than we
realize on the perception of people
being dumb and angry and stupid
is something that is programmed in the
algorithm to make us believe that's true
but i believe it's more rare
than uh it is visible on social media no
no i mean you know i'd like to push back
slightly i guess
you know i think about you know i was
the person who said
trump was not going to win back in the
end of november and got like the race
the tweet that was ratioed into oblivion
20 000 20 000 replies
all the trump supporters being like
you've you've you turned code and i was
right and
i mean like they were all wrong um
and rub it in well right yeah yeah well
i mean if i can't brag
it's like that name you're like why are
you booing i'm right yeah
exactly but there's but the point being
that there was this whole
there was a very very strange political
and
like dynamic among people if you were
any involved in conservative politics at
all where
you were you were walking on a tightrope
during in the
period after the election
pre-inauguration where if you
even tried to do objective analysis that
was even somewhat pessimistic
you were getting like hammered for it i
get it you know a lot of these people
who are supporting trump were
desperate and holding on by threads and
so they needed all the morale they could
get
yeah and if a realist steps in and says
guys guys it's threads man
they're like no like you know they can't
let go yeah
but it wasn't i kept saying this it
wasn't just trump trying to win by the
numbers it was trump versus the machine
yeah it was an issue of can trump win
the votes is one thing
can trump beat the machine through the
legal process
with lawyers with public opinion with
the entire establishment against them
that was a bigger question yeah
and in the end the answer was no however
i do think it's hilarious that even
after they
they beat him in the election they had
to give themselves one
final l like they couldn't just walk
away
they were like let's try an impeachment
we know won't work just to be losers on
the way out give trump the final word
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you